good morning Millennials apologies for
the delay
we pretty much jinxed ourselves a few
weeks ago when we were sitting you're
talking about neither one of us have
ever overslept and it's like crazy and
we've never missed a show and what
happened two weeks ago where I overslept
that I still made it by like 10:35 I
just like over something a half hour
like today I woke up at 10:35 well I was
like I'm II want to be annoying Ella
10:27 and then like times actually
looked back and I was like I wonder at
what point she was concerned that I
wasn't he's I am usually here before I
used to like I wasn't really concerned
about it and then it was like hardcore
10:30 so I asked Margo to check your
location because for some reason you
share your location with Margo and not
me well because she shares her with me
and you don't and I was just like she's
definitely asleep like for sure and I
called your door woman actually yeah and
I was like yo have you seen Jackie she's
like no Zac left but we haven't seen
Jackie I can you upstairs somewhere here
Tori Belle and I thought for sure like
she was gonna say no like why is she
supposed to believe that I'm her sister
I mean but she was lovely very
accommodating she said yeah I'll send
someone up so I said what woke you up
that's what woke me up and I just woke
up with the certainty I literally would
have never woken up otherwise because my
phone is on silent but what's so crazy I
will come at 7:30 Zack had already left
her up really early this morning and I
checked my phone to make sure my alarm
was on so I was like ooh another hour of
sleep let me make sure I don't mean
that's weird so I know my alarm is on I
obviously just turn it off when they
tried to wake me up oh did you I that
they do in my sleep but this time it
went way too far so I think I'm gonna
have to get a real alarm clock because
like this can't happen no you got to get
like an eye home or something yeah I
have to get like a little thing that
runs on the floor and I have to get up
and one of those ones that like slaps
you in the face so have you seen that
one no yeah that's cute they'll be good
for you so anyways like what a [ __ ] show
of morning well now I know the quickest
time I need to get ready and it was the
hard 15 minutes um I'm so we don't worry
I know we did it I mean it's it sucks
for the people who are alive I'm sure
they're having like PTSD I was thinking
like when it was like 11:35 and like I'm
sure I'm getting so many messages
literally like there was none and now
I'm like okay nobody watches our show no
but I think sometimes people give us a
grace period because like things do
happen so I have television people it's
New York City there's always
I think but today was and uh like I just
this is actually my worst nightmare and
I am shocked that it hasn't happened
sooner but it is what it is actually it
happened to you once but I love the
breath yeah but no I was thinking that
also it didn't I didn't oversleep I was
down at the new york-style Shan the
house there was a day where Corinne came
on yes my brain was the day that I was
at the stock exchange a that Olivia
hosted with me you were at the stock
exchange and we just started and you
were gonna come when you got there there
was a day that Olivia hosted with me but
instead I hosted with Korean the day
that you over sucked oh whatever
anyways I'm really sorry guys no it's
all guy I like occasion happen again but
I have no guarantee it was out of my
control it was in my subconscious just
turning off alarm and you know what I'm
surprised I didn't oversleep but these
vivid asks dreams I was having like I
was pregnant and I blacked out and gave
birth and my baby way to give birth by
the end of like of the day that I gave
birth like the baby was already grown up
like it was still wearing like mines
maybe growing about you it was so weird
and I was like you need to stay young
forever and then Theo was breastfeeding
he was so weird it's so weird I think
it's a metaphor about Theo because he's
obviously become so independent yeah and
he's just growing up right before your
eyes no it's true and it's like really
sad my baby was super cute too
oh I'm happy for you well I think I had
a dream about a baby because I was out
to dinner last night and very annoyingly
I got seated next to this party that had
like a baby that was riding her I went
to polo bar that's what I thought
naturally put them on blast but they did
seat Brian and I like literally and the
very back I'd like the worst table with
this group family that was having a 70th
birthday party and like all the babies
were there and it was just like really
annoying well he said haven't you and it
wasn't on your birthday so did that
happen to you like yeah and we had him
really nice time but they took forever
to see this when we clearly had a RZR
that always happens up holeable we're
all there and then like yeah we went
back in whatever but it was nice we were
having a good time so it didn't matter I
don't mind being told that I have to
wait for a table because honestly if
it's like a good vibe me and Brian sat
at the bar we had like four drinks like
that I don't care about and honestly
pull the bars just like a good ambiance
like there are worse places to be stuck
having a drink unless I'm like starving
like I want to kill someone the point is
to be stuck there having injury yeah so
I didn't mind but then it was just like
me and Brian you know we never get
together and then we got together and it
was just like this baby was crying in my
ear and I was just like that's not it
really in a way and that's it's also
like so polymers like so snotty like I'm
surprised they like let that flies it
must've been important also the mother
of the child is important a big child
star the mother of the child was oh my
god was had a fire in her throat what is
it
cat ball fur ball unclear oh my god I
just choked the mother of the child was
the most beautiful woman I'd like it was
sickening how beautiful this woman isn't
like the baby was so fresh but she was
like in this tight jumpsuit like she
looked so skinny I was like now
she was goals she was almost she could
get away with you know having a crying
baby I pull a bar a hundred percent and
she did yeah um
an interesting personal update for me
that I just wanted to share with
everyone is that I joined take top I was
like how odd I saw like what are you
doing well I just realized I was just
like a home I happen to be into storing
a lot and I know I said I would enjoy
talking because like I'm too old and I
don't want to just like be trying to be
young but like that's really what I post
is like those video dancing with dancing
and lip syncing so like immense but post
them on tic toc like and am I trying to
be a tick-tock star and I'm really not
looking for tick-tock fame I'm just
really looking for a creative outlet
bless you she's nice um it's true as you
and a passion project and I think it
could be another passion project as
someone who like firmly believes in the
importance of having passion projects I
really really support you oh thank you
so much you know what maybe one day like
I'll see you on there we can come on
there we can collab imine musically was
turned into a tick-tock when I tried to
be a kid and having musically and it's
like so embarrassing let go check me out
girl in a job that's humiliate it's
human feeling made a thousand accounts
like trying to figure out if I'm gonna
figure out if I ever once made one is
jackieo problem because I can't get that
handle so I'm just Jackie I'm tick-tock
check me out
it's definitely meet like full of
dancing and fun and lip-syncing but also
like the campers are meant for tick-tock
they are and so is the Irish camber
first Irish camber and you can find her
on tick toss speaking of passion
projects make sure you're following two
US news network on Instagram we're
posting premium content all the goddamn
time and we're announcing new shows
sometime soon yeah speaking of passion
projects in tienen this sweatshirt is
moved by lauren elizabeth oh my god it's
so cute I thought let me my lord
Elizabeth package Ross 92 it came with a
very cute vegan leather jacket yes so
vegan also I mean we need to correct
something we said on the show yesterday
about NARS being cruelty-free
it like is in America but it's like not
into
actually it's not fully cruelty-free I
just needed to put a disclaimer out
there okay well then Sephora shouldn't
be going around telling people being the
number one Google search when you
searches NARS cruelty free
well Sephora is also their collection
like Sephora collection brand is not
cruelty free so it's not shocking that
they're covering up the sins of other
Bratz it's full of cruelty yeah very
cruel that's crazy the word cruel oh my
god I just done I just realized cruel
karela deville cuz she's cruel yeah
genius Disney movies are always like you
know shockingly yeah they have so many
different layers well you know what no.1
words like shook you yeah like the word
therapist is the rapist yeah that's
weird
I think definitely not a thing but
actually speaking of words we have a
great story for you today pertaining to
words so without further ado do you
think that it is time I actually think
was time 30 minutes ago so it's time for
the past five story you need to know
before you wake up and take a bed every
morning toast y'all it's time it's time
I won't argue with you but what I will
do is interrupt you because while it is
time I would be I would be so upset I
would almost be like remiss maybe
devastate and even heartbroken no we
couldn't have that yeah if I didn't let
you know that today's episode is brought
to you by one of our newer sponsors
ember wave most public places heat or
cool spaces aiming for a temperature
that is comfortable for only 8% of the
population leaving many people thermally
undeserved and if you're one of the
people who's like entire mood is
predicated off your temperature then
ember wave might just be the technology
for you although ember wave is not a
medical device for those with medical
medical conditions related to
temperature ember wave can help remedy
bursts of temperature extremes or other
uncomfortable sensations ember wave is
there when you need it the most
essentially whatever wave is it's almost
it looks like a bracelet you wear it
around your wrist and helps temperature
control your body so when you're when
you're uncomfortable temperature wise
you can activate your ember wave to
instantly cool or warm science has shown
that cooling or warming sensitive areas
of your body like your wrists improves
your overall comfort just like running
your wrist under cold water to pry view
with provide you with refreshing chill
and cupping your hands around a hot
drink will give you a comfortable
feeling of warmth ember kind of emulates
that and helps just feel your overall I
don't think I've ever used the heating
part of it I only use the cooling no
sweat everywhere I go now that
we're in like a pine bass season I
actually have been using the heating and
it's so nice and delicious and by the
way it helps with unpredictable climates
and in this tough climate change time
period I think an amber wave has never
been more necessary totally pertinent to
the situation it can help you relieve
stress and it can support you when you
sleep because if you're a sweaty sleeper
like I am oh my god it's torture waking
up with like that big puddle of sweat
between your titties it's just it really
is worse some places you can use ember
way to include your off over
air-conditioned office restaurants
airplanes airplanes after workout nails
mall sorry in the car crowded public
spaces and way more they're also having
a Black Friday suburb under sales so you
definitely want to get in on that our
listeners can get sixty dollars off if
they go to ember wave calm slash toast
that's embr wabe comm slash toast one
more time that's am BR wabe comm slash
toast it was invented by three MIT
scientists and hopefully one of them
single sign-on feel amazing works for me
okay
are you ready for our first story it's
really for you yeah I think I'm ready
cuz Taylor Swift is on the cover of
British Vogue looking like British
camper looking incredibly beautiful
looking like snatchy [ __ ] Oh totally
and talking about and to Andrew Lloyd
Webber yeah it was an interesting um
interview where was a third-party
interview so highbrow like she's stoked
by that and now that she's like British
because like she loves Allen boy write
her like hi brownness has been escalated
like to a whole other level I would I
first saw this cover for a second I
didn't think realized that it was her
and then I was like what is this
Photoshop fail but then the more I
looked at it like she really is just
like a model no she's never looked
better
it never looked better it completely
looks like her but it's just like they
whoever did hair and makeup like did a
really good job usually on these covers
they make people look uglier but they
just like she also doesn't do straight
hair that much which I'm loving the
straight hair yeah and I love the length
she's like she's not doing her classic
red lips thing that you like she's going
with more of a Kylie matte which I
wonder if she was using like the k'kaw
Beauty there's no one thousand person
it's like Kim was on set and she
Instagram story and you hear them in the
background listening to love her like
crazy things happen on set like maybe
she really liked one of the Kylie notes
which is the
the artist likes Kylie's formulas yeah
and even though like Taylor Swift
Devlin's like the same makeup artists
like for everything yeah and then you
know it's so crazy it's like so many
celebrities are always like whoring out
their glam and like you don't know who
does Taylor ships hair makeup yeah I'm
sure the stands do but like you don't
see her tagging them on Instagram you
know she pays full price oh for sure uh
anyways to the content because Andrew
Lloyd Webber is interviewing her they're
talking about cats Oh Pat McGrath
actually is all the cosmetics M remember
reading that somewhere so my god such
good stuff that's why she looks so
[ __ ] snatched that's why she's the
snatchler okay good to know so pop
superstar Taylor Swift knows the
upcoming movie adaption of the cat's
musical in which she appears is pretty
strange and that's what she likes about
it quote I had an amazing time with cats
I think I love the weirdness of it she
told Andrew Lloyd Webber the composer of
the original Broadway show who
interviewed her for British Vogue's
January cover story the film's use of
quote digital fur technology to turn
actors into their feline alter egos has
raised eyebrows but Swift who plays
flirty Kitty Bamba run ballerina new
working on the flick would be a
once-in-a-lifetime experience I loved
who I thought I'd never get another
opportunity to be like this in my life
so it's also co-wrote the single
beautiful ghosts with Webber for the
movie whether that song is really good
it's cats is so weird and if you watch
the last season of Kimmy Schmidt they
talked about how weird of course so
funny which was just like and it was
such funny timing that like right after
that it was announced they were gonna
redo cat yeah it's almost like it was
planned yeah and while I'm not the
typical demographic for cats the musical
because I've never seen the actual
musical I don't get it and I don't like
live for the actual animal cats I think
Taylor's kept being in it is like one of
the most brilliant like collaborations
of our time like she's a cat lady and
now she's actually a cat
brilliant agreed now if I hadn't just
seen The Lion King I would have said
this looks so weird same and so stupid
and so creepy but I loved Lion King I
think technology can do incredible
things and I will reserve judgment until
if and when I see it and I'm kind of
here for like Jason Derulo now being
like a respected theatre a respected cat
you see the picture of his penis of
course did you think was fake no no me
neither
no like I just assumed that that's how
they get if you're gonna be like so not
subtle like it can't be fake because
obviously everyone's gonna be talking
about it Jason to really like totally
has a big penis yeah and he's like a
real artist and now I'm really like
excited like he can now put on his
resume he worked with Andrew Lloyd
Webber that's so cool he doesn't need to
say Jason Derulo's David Foster loci
because he's saying I just can't wait to
be king on when David Foster redid all
those Disney songs oh and it's a great
rendition you know that reminds me David
Foster is on tour I think we should go
hit man yeah their name Oh me because
these immense hits yeah no I get it but
a hit man is also like a type of person
who kill someone right for money so I
definitely see the conditioning it
really funny name is it a comedy tour
maybe well I know katharine McPhee is on
it so it must be funny and I think he
has people coming out cuz I don't know
if he himself sings he plays a piano
obviously he can't carry a tune he
definitely can carry a tune but I think
that would be an interesting show to go
to and it was so funny I was like
looking at all the tour dates and I
guess he definitely caters like an older
demographic and like all this the towns
on his tour list we're like retirement
villages Verona town stop
tickets available girls no job calm I'm
gonna be in Ramah Ontario this weekend
hit me up a casino rami gonna want to be
there I'm also going to Tarrytown
Westchester there's like ten tickets
left
Tate's available girl no job calm next
week I'll be in Verona New York which
you by the way I never once have to take
a plane to torture but it's a casino
which I'm very excited for Turning Stone
Casino I think we're all gonna be
tearing stones together we don't worry
that you see no provides our own stones
do not bring your stone i video to
repeat do not bring a stone it's like
not gonna be funny when I'm like on
stage getting stoned to death you know
tons of shows Kansas sitting in Atlantic
City and going tickets available where
they know this is a trick question no
girl with no job calm yeah girls no job
calm one more time girl with no job cop
love it sign-on smell amazing truly um
okay well happy for Taylor Swift that
she like it's just so fashioned so
snatchler yeah etcetera so cats so cats
and it's like I'm I'm excited we're
getting a lot of Taylor Swift content
only because she's doing cats promo and
it's like when are we getting a carpool
karaoke and James Corden is an cats
that's a really good question and I
believe James Corden like announced his
lineup of like next
carpool karaoke accent like she wasn't
on there why wouldn't she do it she'd be
so great at it like people that people
give her so much it for like not being
talented like she's just a pop star she
could really prove herself and she loves
to dance in a seat
this was made for her no I know and it
it's also perfect promo because James
Corden is in cats yeah he has a cat he
is the cat so I just big cat on campus
was James Corden and oh you know we
didn't talk about yesterday recap and TV
that we wanted to kracie Musgraves
Christmas special Tracey Wesker's I
wrote it down in my notes um yes it was
spectacular masterpiece it was
beautifully done honestly was a little
too short because I could have used more
but I would rather be too short than too
loved
coursed Irishman than wanting more it
was just so beautifully done I feel like
she's a very specific aesthetic and it
really came through like in the clothes
and the set in the music and while I
could have lived without Zooey Deschanel
it was it was okay yeah I mean it was
interesting I feel like Casey and I have
so much in common yet all of her choices
her guests are not who I would have
chose Fred Armisen but I thought it was
great
men like Camilla Kibeho really stole the
show she really my opinion on her is
turning ever since the AMAs and the
Kacey Musgraves Christmas special really
helped turn those stones even more yeah
and the looks were just like glam as
hell oh my god they were like sickening
and it was just so cute and cheeky yeah
and we don't we don't get like specials
like that no we get nothing special
nothing no anything special because we
can't have nice things because everyone
ruins them and dan levy was really great
he was he's so funny he's great again I
like how they kept breaking down the
fourth wall being like we hired you to
like be positive and cheery like I liked
that I thought it was really well done I
then I was like funny too like I know
who worked on it Hanna Lux Davis which
is why it was good because everything
she touches is [ __ ] brilliant she's
looking at the rainbow music video for
Casey she she's the definition of in
tune with what's necessary you know I
like if I ever have a music they did
like she must produce it oh my god of
course she did the seven rings music and
the thank you next music video like and
the toast Holiday Edition music videos
she's like really like the go-to
director when it comes to like relevant
music videos these days how did you
percent she's so cool yeah okay are you
ready for our next story
also cool also fun oh is Lizzie McGuire
alum Ethan
Rath is engaged engaged to it Lizzie
look-alike yeah and um the only thing I
learned from this picture of him in his
fiancee is that eating Kraft is still
hot
yeah he's still the snatcher and you
know what it's good because I feel like
see all these stories about like teenage
heart throbs and even like that hot guy
from your high school who's just like
you saw him on Thanksgiving and he ain't
it he's still living in his parents
house this evening craft it's like he's
the Tinsley Mortimer the exception not
the rule where it's just like this can
happen yeah and give up on the high
school man of your dream and he seems
really stable yeah but you know what it
was about Ethan craft the character like
he wasn't a bad guy no that girl Kate
was like always like manipulating him
but he himself was a nice guy he was a
nice guy but he was just like he was the
definition of ignorance is bliss yeah to
the point where it's like he was just a
little too stupid yeah and it's like
you're 16 like you should know and like
you're probably like 25 in real life
yeah and I think that this is just
another moment where it's worth
mentioning that Lizzie McGuire only had
two seasons like I just think not enough
people are talking about that well
they're going into their third this
season now it's the weirdest thing ever
so important the work that you're doing
to shine light on this issue it's
incredibly [ __ ] strange that like and
you know it's sad for the children
because it's like these children only
got two seasons show that they loved and
like nobody even realized no actually
it's a real indicator of how much things
have changed because a show like Lizzie
McGuire could have been so integral in
our upbringings only having had two
seasons whereas these days like no show
would have made as big of an impact with
only two seasons I don't know if the Joe
Josie watch oh yeah do you see Joe Josie
well did you see her Christmas lights no
her house looks nuts it's like filled
with gumdrop stickers all over it should
wrap tit in wrapping paper I feel for
her know I could just see her every
night like taking a hot bath like
dragging on her sexy like how did I get
here
no I know and um like she takes that
ponytail down and like she definitely
has like ball tops because reporting
goes so high unlike ariana grande she
has nerve endings ya know that she's
still young that they're fresh hurts her
no I know like I feel like there's a lot
of pain behind that ponytail obviously
physical pain but more like emotional
pain and they just feel like she just
wants to be who she is like she loves
and she also had like her Jojo see where
I wrapped BMWs sitting in the front in
the driveway like she's gonna get robbed
so like if everyone knows where she
lives like you drive by the house like
my wonder who lives her I think Jojo see
what
I think so too okay well I'm really
happy for Ethan Kraft this picture was
so cute it was a throwback and it's
really great promo for this upcoming
season of lizzie mcguire Z in it um I'm
not sure has to be might as well be even
but if Ethan and Lizzie like we're like
living together in the big city like
they fell in love like where do we get
where do we pick up I know it took a
couple Millennials it's basically
younger Millennials living in Manhattan
and it's like is Lizzie a pop star now
because she took the stage in Italy and
she never looked back right so I wonder
if they're like gonna address that at
all like the controversy she looked back
once and she shook her shoulders um oh
yeah I look for obviously its younger
I'm literally just you know and that's
okay
I wonder if they work in publishing yeah
did you finish the season him younger I
don't think so it was good I like it I
think it's just such a fun easy to watch
show and any time Peter Herman is like
you know in my bedroom I'm okay with
that right even though I'm like what's
going on on the screen isn't like
exactly what I would have written it's
just fun to watch yeah it is a little
annoying how like Charles and Liza like
can never get their [ __ ] together like
whenever they it's like good even this
season it's like it's bad yeah like by
the way and the weeds just suspend
disbelief at someone like Charles would
ever travel to Brooklyn like and sleep
in a loft right has a perfectly lovely
town out of town she works in the city
why wouldn't she sleep there every night
also she's living with her roommate like
for free her friend like threw her a
bone it's the bones up and the bug has
been chewed like and also how does
Maggie pay rent on that Lots for being
like an artist
oh I mean she probably has like uh rent
stabilization she's probably been there
forever you know she's like Lily at
Lilian from me she lives in the side of
a boat yeah that was also a weird thing
Lilian was like a weird character with
that guy who died my a she like was
fighting to keep his protect his legacy
like I'm like his daughter Sheba this
show took a really [ __ ] weird turn it
really did but anyways I understand how
Debi Mazar pays the rent but like oh
what's her name
younger Liza Liza that's Congress uh
Liza wasn't supposed to live with her
forever so it's like you finally caught
a man get out move uptown yeah or like
at least stop spending so much time at
your loft and bringing your man's there
yeah and your kid
and your friends right a friend's
friends oh she's out of control she's a
real Shannara like the way she just kind
of like took over Maggie's apartment
it's so not right and so she's a
creative she needs a space to sing and
josh is always there we're tired of
suffering oh and the one person they
bring in like stole her art oh that was
really sad that was so weird
also when Debi Mazar got stuck in that
harness upside down yeah those honey
that was really good show she's the best
part of the show I would agree
I took me a while to realize that and
appreciate her yeah and nobody in the
cast appreciates her like Liza doesn't
realize like how good of a friend she
has she's I was like like not she was
like be belittling know what's the word
I'm blank off it's like when you bug off
know when you like cancel plans like
blank like you're always um it's like um
blowing off lemon off thank you Wow um
agreed and but I do feel like Kelsey has
a little bit of respect for her because
I feel like Kelsey was the one who tells
he's only won in the show with her head
on straight oh yeah of course except
she's a little nuts too yeah she stopped
just having sex with everyone like
that's a problem no it really is a
problem well congratulations
Ethan craft looking forward to Lacey
Maguire I have to get Disney Plus but
right now I'm watching the crown until
nothing else matters yeah I only have
three more episodes laughter I'm so
upset and I know like as Verizon
customers we get a free year of Disney
Plus but like I'm just so unsure about
how to go about finding that free
subscription only applied like one
television and the signature Eddie
snatched it did she yeah of course
that's why she was asking for the
Verizon login oh my god that's why she's
the snatchler
that's why she's a snatchler I'm so
excited for this week's episode of the
snatchler because she is having Olivia
on and like honestly Margot and Nicole
need to talk to Olivia like an adult
yeah and Olivia's gonna set them
straight I think it's gonna be like
great for Margot Nicole and also
everyone who listens who's in their
position as well did you I think it's
gonna be transformative okay next up
Kendall Jenner is getting a new show
with her twin brother I saw this it's on
kwibi Oh kwibi is that app that like
people in the industry like I've been
taking meetings like everyone just like
talks about kwibi for five years like
people have been talking about this
program it's like a new streaming
service that's
it's like long form short content it's
ten minute episodes like that's like the
max you can't have anything longer than
10 minutes on kwibi um it has like a ton
of investment so I people are just like
flocking towards it but I don't think
any consumer actually gives a [ __ ] about
it but they're coming up with ideas
that's also in the most recent episode
of Kardashians or two episodes ago where
they were talking about Chloe and trues
TV show and there was a mark on the wall
and she couldn't stop thinking about it
that was quit me too so it's obvious
that the Kardashians have a big deal
with kwibi oh my god that's so interpret
pendal Jenner obviously it has no part
of the show except her name on it and
making money because it's about an
Instagram if it's a kirby Jenner yeah
exactly
maybe Jenner got famous on Instagram for
photoshopping him selves into photos of
the Kardashians and it's actually really
funny like the Kardashians have noticed
him a bunch of times over the years so
it's obvious that like Kendall like they
have a relationship yeah sorry now that
I know this son could be like it's just
not as no it's like who cares yeah it's
like it's it's a web show I think they
decided to make a youtube video together
I don't care yeah um but kendall Jenner
was in the Kacey Musgraves Christmas
special yeah and you know I'm actually
I'm about to blow everyone's mind I've
never seen Love Actually so I didn't
know that those signs was like a nod to
that I'm like why aren't they talking oh
yeah I mean that makes it so much better
and I'd love actually also Christmas
with me yes so it's a V Christmas movie
got it
well it's something Christmas movie elf
is but ya know but like Love Actually
it's like you know Valentine's it's a
Christmas rom-com you know Valentine's
Day - starring Taylor Swift of course
that's the Valentine's Day version of
Love Actually got it same director and
everything where it's like a bunch of
different people's Christmas story lines
in one relate New Year's yes New Year's
Eve New Year's Eve um I loved Kendall in
the Christmas special
I just loved everything about it and
even him too looked sick if she looked
like so stunning and Casey and I loved
their friendship and like that's who I
would have called on a Kardashians yeah
I think the evolution of their
friendship is incredibly interesting
because as you know we reported like two
years ago how they first were publicly
tied together was Kendall put up an
Instagram story while she was sitting on
the balcony of her hotel room at the
Bowery Hotel and in the background was a
bit more for Casey's new album goals an
hour at the time and Kendall Jenner like
blurred it out and it was really weird
and people were like commenting like why
did you blur out her billboard like yeah
it was almost like she didn't want to
promote it and then she like gave some
half-ass apology being like oh
of these cavities my ask my friends in
local music it was like the most
fake-ass apology but I guess maybe she
really does talk with country music
because she went to Cannes he went to
the Kardashian Halloween party I do
believe they went to her show in LA so
it's real uh yes very real I'm a big fan
of the friendship we take so far we've
come so far okay next story is brought
to you by cope re a brand that we
absolutely love and adore here and we
would be RDH if we didn't mention them
we'd be Rd here's a harsh reality almost
rth just because it's not warm out
doesn't mean you don't sweat so I think
true so even though you might be making
changes to your beauty routine this
winter there are some things you need to
get year-round so yes I find that I
definitely moisturize my wenis --is and
my face way more in the winter and I
don't really realize like I should be
hydrating my armpits like just as much
just as much if not more and we have
been using the cope re aluminum free
coconut geo Durant for obviously being
here now that they've been sponsoring
the toes and I first I was like a little
nervous about transferring over to
natural deodorant but ever since I did I
like I'm literally like the face of
clean beauty you are no I am I'm the
armpit of clean beauty go parties
coconut children is a cleaner
alternative to traditional deodorants it
is aluminum free vegan it does not
contain any silicone sulfates parabens
GMOs or baking soda when thinking about
putting like a drugstore deodorant on
your armpits your armpits are like
actually like a really important part of
your body like you have glands there and
I just think it's a really irresponsible
thing to do and I can't believe that
like since middle school like I was
using like so many chemicals in my
deodorant chemicals it's crazy and and
like the chemicals require more
chemicals because you come immune and
then you have like an armpit full of
chemical instead of using a bunch of
questionable ingredients you probably
don't want in your body cope are is to
your durang keeps you fresh with plan
please pant plant-based actives like
sage oil and coconut oil and since
you're never going to not need yo drink
o party made it so you never have to run
out you can subscribe subscribe and get
automatically we're gonna can't speak
you can subscribe and get deodorant
automatically shipped to your door as
often as you choose for free kapo'i
offers a money-back guarantees so if
you've been thinking about switching to
a cleaner deodorant this is the time and
the best way to do it go to cope re
beauty.com slash toast to get 15% off
your monthly subscription orders that's
cope re
KO PA RI beauty.com slash toast Khepera
beauty calm
/ toast sign-on smell amazing yeah
without chemical from the inside out um
I love Co Perry you know I think would
like cope re someone from our next story
Brad Pitt I think he would - it's pretty
natural he dated Kourtney Kardashian in
our dreams wisely getting sick I think
so Wow take it easy let's have dinner
tonight and tomorrow night but I think
what's with all these dinners you know
what I've been finding that it's such
I'm really glad you asked that because
like might at for the last like 18
months my time at home has been so
limited I think for the first half of
going on tour whenever I was home I was
like I need to be home home um but then
it's like if I am only in bed every time
I'm home like how what am I ever gonna
see my friends so I've really been
making like in the last few months like
an active choice to like see people on
the weeknights but it's like I'm so
tired so tired but like you could do it
all I mean you had four drinks
fascinating you showed up here on time I
watched the crowd and I overslept you
just like that's absolutely true you
know the person it's about like it was
irresponsible man plans God laughs so
what are you doing tonight I was gonna
have maybe like a sushi dinner but I'm
just really not feeling good okay take
it easy
maybe I'll take it easy today and then
tomorrow night but also I find it really
difficult to go out on the week nights
and also what show up here having
watched all my television right and if I
have a drink at dinner and then come
home and watch a real house I was like I
don't remember what happened no that's
how I feel - but you could do that last
May because there was nothing on right I
always forget because Monday nights are
so heavy in the beginning of the year we
have bachelor Dancing with the Stars we
have two hours we have Vanderpump rules
sometimes yeah so now we're in a season
where there's nothing on on Monday
nights and it's kind of lovely yeah it's
a great way to slice into the week well
speaking of having a drink Brad Pitt
opens up about past mistakes in drinking
he has been talking like he's been
opening up a loss in an open book quote
it was a disservice to myself as an
escape I mean I just like loved him in
any glimpse that we can get into his
like my mind is so welcome and he's just
so like why it seems like now he's
really on the straight and narrow like
he's a good role model now yeah Brad
Pitt has a new lease on life in a
conversation with Anthony Hopkins for
Interview magazine published on Monday
Pitt reflected on his past mistakes and
why
struggles may have been necessary to get
him to the place he's in today quote I'm
realizing it is the year of realizing
stuff mhm I'm realizing he said as a
real act of forgiveness for myself for
all the choices that I've made that I'm
not proud of that I value those missteps
because they led me to some wins wisdom
which led to something else do you think
Angelina like reads these interviews and
like rolls her eyes or it's like she was
trying to change a man for so long it
was obvious l-like a lot of his toxic
behavior was happening during their
marriage so now she's like oh of course
a second I leave like you're normal no I
think she's not even like reading these
interviews she's just like throwing the
magazine's across the room yeah I feel
like what an interesting marriage they
were like when they first got together
like it was so radioactive like we told
Jennifer Aniston thing miss her mrs.
Smith like did they blur the lines like
what were they together like before to
him and Jen broke up I kind yeah and it
ended up being like the most like stable
we thought like marriage like not only
did they get there like a thousand kids
like they were philanthropy it's like
they had like this really like like
humble life and now it's like all coming
on that he was like so not Santaland the
playing like alcohol so what a what did
it what an important couple like in pop
culture history they really are and like
I just really feels badly cuz I feel
like I was on the wrong side of it whose
side were you on
Angelina what during the marriage the
whole time like I just totally shipped
Angelina and Brad I thought they were
ending like who cares if we're stomping
all over tenifer Aniston's heart it's
not about her yeah and like now I'm just
like oh my god can Brad and Jen get back
together yeah no I actually like low-key
think like that would be crazy but like
not that crazy anymore you know and not
at all I do actually feel bad for
Jennifer Aniston because like all like
she's in a really accomplished actress
but like all she'll ever be known for it
was like being the woman that Brad Pat
left left for Angelina Jolie do you know
what I mean and like she's I don't think
that a week has gone by since 2008 where
she hasn't been on the cover of a
tabloid talking about Brad or
relationships but he's not her like it's
yeah the media it's me it's like it's
actually terrible it's really such a
crazy thing that happens
yeah and for a while I feel like they
showed up because she was with Justin
Theroux but now she's not with Justin
Theroux so she needs to get back
together with Brad and like I just want
to issue an apology like even though we
didn't have a show and
I never said anything like in my heart I
just felt yeah by the way and I feel
like that really swayed what happened
Lily here's something really interesting
because someone posted in the toasters
group a little while ago I finally read
that interview John Mayer did with
Rolling Stone that like caused him to
like take that like five-year break move
to Montana like where everyone thought
he was like the biggest douchebag in the
world and he definitely had some like
really off-color things in um in the
interview but I didn't think it was like
that douchebag II like you the way he
was just talking about like sex with
women but he spoke a lot about Jennifer
honesty and I'm like I don't think I
ever realized like that was the one that
got away from me I always thought that
Katy Perry was the one that got away
from John Mayer but I actually think it
was Jennifer Addison like this article
was really interesting I just thought of
it as a fling like he dated Jessica
Simpson like I just thought Jennifer
Aniston was just as much of a fling as
Jessica Simpson was but but he wasn't
and like he wouldn't even really talk
about Jessica Simpson or any of the
other celebrities that he dated in that
article out of respect to Jen he's like
I don't want her name to be in the same
article as Jessica Simpson that's what
everybody said it was just like it was
really shocking that's crazy yeah cuz I
just don't think of them I always forget
that they dated
let me think she get back together no I
I actually think that they could it
seems like he's really matured a lot and
that's what she wanted from him he was
like a 35 girl like kid because he
became a rock star
but now he's so stable that I actually
think he like the time might be right
for them even though I do well hold out
hope for him and Katy Perry like I'm
showing up the Grammys together when she
wear that great degree dress and he wore
that blue velvet suit like that will
forever be the most iconic moment in pop
culture history what about John Mayer
and Taylor Swift um toxic like your two
number-one toxic I don't I don't ship
them at all like I do not think they
could want to for more different things
in life I think that though what really
drew them to each other was like their
love of song writing but that's not
enough to hold a marriage and kids like
they are so different but they just both
love writing music and I think they had
and still have a lot of respect for each
other from this in the songwriting
sphere but I do not think by any means
that they are right for each other
understood if I were to ship Taylor with
anyone that she previously dated it
would obviously be Harry Styles because
I do think in a lot of ways they're
perfect they're so wrong for each other
perfect I ship her and Tom Hiddleston I
don't know why I didn't work yeah
actually I know they were perfect for
each other you know that in the Taylor
ship fandom he is the least favorite
boyfriend of hers but I actually think
the best boyfriend for her was Calvin
Harris no
he's the least favorite boyfriend for
her because like he totally disrespected
her
oh no the way they ended was awful and
like the fact that he was like tweeting
things about his beard and then that
whole how deep is your love thing like
he was so disrespectful and I did not
like that at all but I liked who she was
in that relationship she's it's just a
cool girl who took her jet to Vegas to
see her boyfriend TJ and omneya yeah
with him but I don't think that she
likes who she was like I think that was
the beginning of the end she was caring
about the wrong things back then yeah
yeah yeah I'm cool with Jo I just have
know him enough
I love Calvin Harris like but I don't
think that they were right together it
was too good to be true I've ever seen a
picture of Calvin Harris's penis no
maybe I have now seen two pictures one
video and one pictures right
oh no well I saw it um I saw the picture
like this it's circulated on Twitter
like you can find it I'm not sure if
it's even real but then I saw a little
boomerang video thing of a penis that he
sent to someone and it was um it was
quite shocking like it was uh
extraterrestrial no good for him yeah
good for him but I don't participate in
celebrity news no I don't either
um P the final story a little linguist
is okay you can't do that like sort of
like like inflection in your voice
bitten by a story a lot of linguistic
news are you sure yes I business it's
not the word linguistics gives me a
post-traumatic stress disorder because
when I was a freshman at NYU I had to
take a general arts and science class
for four credits and Olivia was a senior
and she also did so we decided to take
one together because we were in college
together for one year and we're like
let's take a class together and we took
this class called linguistics of the
world languages of the world no sorry it
was legit linguistics : languages of the
world and I got an F I know I got an F
Olivia got a C and you know what I was
really happy to take the F because if
she got that she wouldn't be able to
graduate cuz she needed the credits and
they like they said like you have to
retake it if you wanna get the credits
and I never retook it it was too
traumatizing it was the hardest [ __ ]
class so did you have to take five
classes one semester for extra credit no
so what I did was I was always taking 18
credits every semester instead of 16 cuz
I took a two credit voice lesson so in
two semesters
got it sweet well teaching dictionary
coms word of the year for 2019 is
existential ooh what does it mean way
existential bro what does it mean I know
like existential crisis yeah I still
don't even know what that means we
define the adjective existential in two
senses the first is of or relating to
existence you can't use the word and I
agree dictionary 101 come on Miriam and
during English in the late 1600s this
existential is often used when the fact
of someone are something's being it's
very existence is at stake an
existential threat to a species for
example plus its continued existence in
real concrete peril and what qualifies
for being word of the year our second
sense of existential is concerned with
the nature of human existence as
determined by the individuals freely
made choices I have a question why did
you pick this story because I think
words of they are so interesting dude
was justice last year yes we which we
were definitely responsible then also
there's a difference between dictionary
coms word of the year and Miriam Webster
what's this this is dictionary calm oh
this is lowbrow no Merriam Webster's
thirsty
she's like socks yeah like by the
Merriam it's very thirsty and I do feel
as though dictionary calm really tries
to pick a word that like sums up the
times and they do feel as though
everyone feels as though we are living
in existential times what does that mean
like it's the end of life how so
like it's just like such crises well if
it is the end of life I want to go out
looking snatched you know I want to look
my absolute best for the end of the
world and I think the only way to do
that is to sign up for noon a hundred
percent if you have specific goals you
want to achieve or you have achieved
basically Noom here this is how they
described it Newman's a habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses and I told
you guys the craziest story was that I
went to the doctor for a checkup
and she was asking me if I use any apps
to like count calories or track my food
and I was like actually because she goes
the only one I really recommend I think
a lot of them are [ __ ] is noob and I
said excuse me did you go to new console
s host based on psychology new teaches
you why you do the things you do and
arms you with the tools to break the bad
habits and replace them with better ones
they say it's based on cognate cognitive
behavioral
approach but we just say it works noon
is not a diet it is a healthy and easy
to stick to way of life no food is
considered good bad or off-limits on you
they teach you moderation then can be
used in conjunction with many
pre-existing popular diets if you want
that's kind of why I like it as someone
who makes poor food choices I think for
me just to expect myself to like stop
eating what I eat altogether like that's
kind of unrealistic and will lead me to
go crazy and just psyched go off the
rails but if I can have what I like in
moderation I think that's a really
healthy way of thinking about things
one of the biggest and most numa's one
of the most biggest one of the most I
can't even speak Newman is the biggest I
know it's one of the biggest and most
accurate food databases available and
that lets you track your meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance we are all strapped
for time numa's just asking you to
commit 10 minutes a day for yourself you
are human if you go off track there's no
shaming just tips to help you get back
on track tomorrow you don't have to
change it all in one day take small
steps to make big progress sign up for
your trial today at noon calm / toast
what do you have to lose visit n oom
dot-com / toast new mom / toast to start
your trial today that's Noom calm /
toast the last weight-loss program
you'll ever named me okay so existential
is word of the year I think like in the
being inspired by cher Horowitz we
should try and use the word existential
it's in everyday life a hundred percent
and I hope she does use the word
existential and I just want to give you
a little bit more context from Richie
cher Horowitz oh yeah
the word existential framed the
conversation of the story set to find 20
19 across topics across the globe from
business and education to science and
sports they give a bunch of different
highlights that like really highlight
this existential crises we live in Hong
Kong protests brexit big tech notre-dame
fire you know no I so they do oh and
then the runner-up for word of the year
are you ready for any non-binary
see that I do feel really encapsulates
the essence of 2019 a hundred percent
interesting speaking of the existential
as it relates like climate change is
right one speaking of the notre-dame
fire I feel like it was such a big
look what happened today we built um I
think they're rebuilding they got so
much money today yeah
remember when like I put up a meme about
it and like you couldn't make jokes
about it people were so crazy sensitive
because like everyone was posting
pictures of them in Paris being like oh
so sad what's happening in Paris like we
gotta you went to Paris and I put up a
hilarious Whitney Cummings tweet and
literary people came to me so hard
really yeah well I feel like after with
Notre Dame what happened like so many
people were so devastated about like a
building that went on fire and they gave
so much money and then all these other
crises were happening and like people
are like you weep for Notre Dame but not
like action where like nobody died yeah
it is really sad like it's a religious
space and we're not diminishing that at
all but I definitely see why it can be
frustrating to like you can't even rally
people to give a [ __ ] about like the
Santa Ana winds but like here we are
you can't rally people to clean up that
Susana
Susan Center right but like I asked TPG
about like the bowing drama and he
hadn't heard about this Susanna Susan
field so I was telling him like the
Kardashian the whole thing and he was
just say like Boeing is having a year
okay and I just like not this isn't
necessarily a business show but I'm
about to give some stock advice um I
feel like you should short Boeing
because like after this Kardashian's
episode like they're just gonna go in
the tank I feel it Oh 1,000% but I don't
own any Boeing stock so you can like
instead of Bangkok you can just like buy
short I understand that you saw the big
short I did but I still don't know what
that means it's such a good movie you
know I watched it well I started it and
I just couldn't get through it and I'm
sometimes that people like love it so
much because I really didn't like it
it's brilliant like not only is it a
good movie but you learn so much about
what happened in 2008 and I remember I
was just a junior a sophomore in high
school and I think there was a recession
but like how do things receipt and they
all just happened on one day because
like no is the date that the loans were
scheduled to flap the the recession was
such a crazy time like I always forget
like when like that part in our lives
were like it was a recession like it
really affected a lot of things
hmm it affected everything like and as a
kid like you don't think about the
economy but like I remember in our my
middle school every year the 8th graders
went to Israel and they had to cancel
the trip until an anonymous donor funded
the whole thing that's very kind thing
you know it was very
but like if I ever ever rich enough to
like being on mr. toner like I'm not
being anonymous like I want everyone to
know like yeah I'm saving the children's
trip like that's me like I want a plaque
or something yeah like and we're like
whenever you're in like buildings like
hospitals or like even like like shools
and said this wing was donated by
anonymous I'm like are you going did you
ever see that episode of karma it's what
kind of name is that
yes Jewish last name of course we're Ted
Danson does the whole thing anonymously
yeah Larry doesn't and like Larry looks
like an [ __ ] there's an episode of
Curb for like every situation
there's never sort of friends for every
situation that is also true but what
I've realized is there an episode of
friends about donating lake to charity
yes oh my god wait and I told you about
it because um Joey challenges Phoebe and
it's like no no uh yeah Joey challenges
Phoebe is like you can never do a good
deed completely selfishly because in a
lot of ways you're just doing it to make
yourself feel better at the end of the
day like no good deed is really selfless
and so she like hold the whole episode
like does different acts of charity to
like make it seem like he's wrong but he
actually ends up being right like she
lets a bee sting her but then she always
like this
the be probably dies after he stings you
so it's not really good she bled a beast
and I can't that's why I don't want
friends anyways it's givingtuesday
oh it is givingtuesday so feel free to
donate to your local charities but if
you can't think of one donate to the
gift of life bone marrow registry it's a
great service and I think everyone
should donate and you should also be in
the registry okay
okay yourself a swab kit you just put a
q-tip in your mouth it takes ten seconds
okay you could save someone's life don't
be an [ __ ] I think you guys so much
oh so housekeeping announcements we have
merged coming out this Friday December 6
1 p.m. eastern time at shop morning
chest calm we're gonna start teasing the
items on our instagrams we have holiday
sweaters we have a robe we have tons of
new sweats
lots of apparel I think you guys are
really gonna like to be in beanies it's
gonna be really good stuff so make sure
you're following us on Instagram and you
don't miss the drop this Friday at 1
p.m. Eastern Time at shop morning toast
comm tickets for my tour are bail buck
or Athan job calm if you would like some
more premium content feel free to follow
Jackie on tik-tok what's your username
now Jackie O'Shea ok cute you couldn't
get Jackie oh I couldn't get anything
that's true Jackie O problem usually no
I think like I took it like a million
years ago
and that's right I tried logging in from
every email address I have and they just
was making a million account like I have
the dishes tick-tock app on my phone
like I've got many times that I'm hosing
something like I just can't think of
anything like how do these kids like
come up with these ideas well I feel I'm
not gonna be a tick tock or like they're
so creative and it's really like buying
those funny videos that are like spiced
together but I just like want to dance
and sing and I want to do it in a place
where other people dancing yeah yeah I
think it's very much a community I think
so to think you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
and yes I guess it's got a question how
this stuff ships immediately everything
is in stock you know if you were
ordering it as a Christmas gift for
someone in here is with ample time for
the holidays we have such fun stuff that
you haven't even seen yet I was just
remembering ornaments Oh Josie or in a
mess or in a min we have stockings if
you want to put them on your mantel
stuff a little uh we have ones limit of
robes we have sweatshirts me of like
ugly Christmas ugly Hanukkah sweatshirts
that are like not actually ugly and it's
just a really good time so we will see
you on Friday at you have more neato
calm but we also see you tomorrow right
here I'm so sorry for over sleeping
everyone I let you down it won't happen
again thank you too much listening to
the morning show someone a morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to subscribe to us on youtube
you give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcast can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher podcast radio I
already know all the places all the
radios so please subscribe to us
anywhere you listen to podcasts leave us
a five star review about I was studying
smart and beautiful we are we love you
guys so much have a wonderful Tuesday we
will see you tomorrow
you